new zealand is taking urgent action to  prevent the spread of covet 19 putting  the city of auckland  on lockdown after four new cases popped  up  there had been no new infections in that  country for more than three months  officials are investigating whether the  virus in auckland was imported by  freight  the country's director general of health  says all of the infections were found  within one household  she says surface testing is underway at  a store where a man  from the infected family worked michelle  what's remarkable about this story is  all of auckland is going on lockdown  right now and that's exactly the way  health officials say  you flatten the curve and as both of you  know in this country it's a struggle  just to get people in some states to  wear masks  the prime minister has been relentless  in fighting this disease  she is not letting up and just another  example of it